robotic snakes sound like the stuff of
nightmares but their limbless movements
make them good candidates for exploring
land sea and air on a recent expedition
to Egypt a robotics team ran into
trouble their Robo snake couldn't make
its way of sandy inclines we're often is
interested in failures of locomotive
models as we are in success is because
the failures help us understand some of
the principles meanwhile a physics team
in Georgia was working out the
biomechanics of snakes on tilted sandy
soils we thought to ourselves what's a
very cool animal that no one has looked
at as it turned out robots aren't the
only ones who have problems with the
sand but one snake had no issues
ascending the steepest slopes the
Sidewinder rattlesnake when Sidewinders
sidewind
they're actually sending two waves down
their body one in the horizontal plane
and one in the vertical plane where
these waves meet determines which part
of their bodies move ahead and which
stays stuck to the soil their secret to
tackling slopes increasing the
proportion of their bodies that stayed
in contact with the sand as the slope
got steeper it's harder than it sounds
after teaming up the researchers use
what they learn from the Sidewinder is
to improve the Robo snake because the
snake bot showed improvement it meant
that their understanding of sidewinding
mechanics is accurate and now it has the
skills to slither up all the dunes in
Egypt go
you